hello cohort one
it's meeting 18 we're in our second
discussion on
chapter seven
let's go to the questions and see what
we can explore today
or see where else to go
and or
look towards chapter eight but there's
any number of ways we can do it so
first just on chapter seven
does anyone want to uh
turn to any of these questions add
another question add another
reflection or a thought that arose in
the last week
one question that I um
had was
are there any ways or sweets
for for example taking in an analytical
expression
and then providing equivalent
phrasings
that might have other advantages
Ali
you mean by translating it into natural
language
or like
like what we saw in equation 2.5 and 2.6
like to take in an expression
and then
output
[Music]
um
isomorphic or I guess not isomorphic but
equivalent expressions Expressions that
have the exact same
value as calculated
because some some of the and when we
look through the derivation sometimes
it's possible to trace the trail but to
know which representations of perhaps
even the same
functional
or same
term
it seems quite relevant
actually there's a an AI assistant for
deriving formal proofs for mathematical
theorems but uh I haven't used it myself
but I'm not sure if that's what you mean
I'll look at the
book the name of that and what just one
second I'll post hmm
maybe there's a way to
um
reformulate
these
um specific terms from like a Bayesian
mechanics
uh
formalism like posterior predictive
predicted entropy
that looks like something that Dalton
probably described as well
the question is whether you can just
interchange it
yeah does working with the particular
partition
enable equations to be operated with
more composably
because we can know that
there are certain
operations that are
um like always sometimes never going to
be valid
I'm just kind of asking I don't even
know if that's the threat with a habit
um
so last time we talked primarily about
the
um
Mouse
in the maze
and we're going through
uh the way that the this the chapter is
layering on
features of the model
so first we saw
the mouse just go for it
and now we're going to be uh it gets
where it gets the queue
and this comes to our earlier points
about the resolution of the explore
exploit
trade-off
foreign
anyone can give a thought while I'm
adding it what are posterior predictive
entropy and expected ambiguity
the part of the decomposition of
epistemic value
foreign
let me just make sure to say the
posterior
predictive entropy
is the expected surprise or the entropy
of the distribution of observations
conditioned on a policy
so we're in expected free energy world
we're talking about
um
evaluating policies
with respect to now putting aside
pragmatic value we're talking about
decompositions of how the informational
or the epistemic
value of a policy is evaluated
so there's two terms here
first
how dispersed
is your distribution of outcomes
for that policy
one can imagine that all things being
equal you would want to select policies
that have a tighter distribution of
outcomes
here
we have an expectation interestingly
um this is italics e
but it's not a fancy e
do people think there's a difference
that matters or do they think that's a
slight error
I think there should be a typo yeah I'm
going to add it to erata
e is
italics
should be fancy e
okay
it's the expectation
over our hidden State estimates
condition on a policy
and it's the expectation of
the expected ambiguity so
entropy
of
the a matrix
functionally how outcomes depend on
States
so this is saying I want to be
I want to be more
um
is it the case that it says I want to be
more certain
about observations
and how they uh map to policy
and
I want to have a tighter a matrix
Eric
so um knife question why is there an
expectation on the right and now on the
left
I was also going to ask this isn't
entropy already the expectation of
surprise
foreign
just just so another another point of um
clarification for myself that
I want to make sure this is right is um
the um the O tilde is observations
and what we're looking at here is a
functional
Q
so that's something that's
that's a distribution
of
observations that will get over policy
and that's what's being adjusted in the
free energy so we're going to explore
the uh the distributions Q
and the otilda's are going to be
um
past observation so we're not not
looking forward there we're looking
past because those are actual
observations they're not predicted
through
um the the hidden States s
so straighten that out
are we sure that oh our only past
observations I believe that past
observations are accounted for
with respect to how they influence
the prior
um
but does otilda also include
future observations
well if so then it has to be an
expectation over something that mustn't
it
like but this is conditioned upon a
given policy
then
these are the this is the time series of
observations
expected under that policy
is the left term
the Q expected
distribution of
observations conditioned on policy Jacob
I was just going to uh say that I think
I've seen uh this in other parts of the
book as well and I think they use the
H and then just the expectation notation
for entropy kind of interchangeably
um okay if they do but then isn't this
like a double expectation
this is the this is the expectation of
surprise on the queue but this is the
expectation
of the expectation of surprise
yeah uh
that I don't know
Eric
okay okay but the left term
just um yeah Ali please
uh well shouldn't that first line uh I
mean the H the both
H is
shouldn't both of them
be as the argument of the expectation
according to equation 7.4
because in equation 7.4 we have the
negative epistemic value
but it's somehow different from this
equation yeah that's it
okay
so in 7.4 we see a re
statement
of
expected free energy equation two six
let's leave pragmatic value to the side
for now
here
we see fancy e q s tilde Pi so this is
looking like this probably could or
should
we also see h p o s h p o s
minus
HQ o pi
okay so let's take the negative of the
first line
the negative of the first line
you can kind of just flip the terms
it's the expected ambiguity now minus
the the posterior predictive entropy
then
an expectation is being taken over that
oh sorry sorry my bad I felt the the
square brackets I mean it was
encompassing the whole expectation term
sorry sorry
no no you're you're right actually um oh
well there's a lot of layers of it
I I always write as it's written okay
okay yeah yeah
um
okay wait
I always color my brackets when I'm
trying to do this um okay the the
outermost bracket there actually may be
a bracket I don't even know let's try to
figure it out the outer bracket starts
here on the left and it and then it
closes okay pragmatic value if we take
that as a standalone
if we take that as standalone
is anyone else seeing a bracket sort of
scenario
if we look at the brackets as a whole
this first bracket closes this right
Mouse uh I don't think so the first
bracket closes at the end of the S tilde
yeah okay okay yeah parenthesis
okay okay bracket yeah that's okay well
I was confused too I got I I agree that
was I was thinking should we evaluate
the brackets locally
but yes they they are
okay good
okay so it's exactly the negative of
equation seven point eight left side
here is the negative of
so
the first term
um let's just say it in terms of picking
good policies
we want
policies are better with more clarity
about observation outcomes that's the
first term
and a tighter a matrix
that's the second term
okay
middle line
this is a KL Divergence
between
the product two two products of
distributions
both of them are dealing with
o
in the first and s in the second
the Q distribution in the second part is
the same for both
so maybe there's some interactions in
how distributions of different kinds
multiply
but
it may be fair to interpret this as um
the POS
is the a matrix
and the q o pi
is how observations are
shaped by policy
or another way to say it might be
POS
is outcome expectations conditioned upon
hidden states of the world
whereas this is outcome distributions
conditioned on what we do
I mean to me that just looks like like
base you know base law there because
you've got
um at least in the
in the left side a little bit because
you've got condition on S and then s
conditioned on pi
so you're just
basically saying you're trying to
figure out what o is from PI through
this intermediary s Delta
oh one so
another angle would be where's this zero
well this is zero
when
these two are identical
the epistemic value of a policy is low
when it when the
resulting o distribution
is being unconditioned by the policy
that we choose
whereas for policies that change how we
think about the a matrix
those policies have higher informational
value
because POS is kind of like a policy
agnostic mapping
but we're like drilling down to kind of
sub variance partitions
of informational value these are
different ways to look at
what makes a policy
have epistemic value
the first one line was coming down to uh
clarity
around the tightness of outcome
distributions
the second one is related to
how
policy
deviates our understanding of the a
matrix
okay
now let's turn to
okay here's another
um italic e not a fancy e
thank you Ali for this link I've I've
heard of this one the the [ __ ] proof
assistant but I've never seen it used or
anything
yeah
this looks pretty pretty interesting I
wonder if anyone has done that kind of
formal work on proving certain parts of
fep
and then a more distal
um
question
would be if we have formal ontology
representations for example with sumo or
otherwise
could we make proofs
around the ontology
and the Sumo
um suggested upper merged ontology
we explored some of those things but
didn't didn't go super super far
it was just the the it's it's it yeah
take somebody who knows that area
okay
the bottom term the bottom line
an expectation over q but now our Q
is on outcomes
not
focusing on the hidden States
then it's an expectation
about outcomes
of
a kale Divergence
between
it's about this is about hidden States
this kale Divergence
is zero
when outcomes
are not
when in addition to policy outcomes
don't change how we think about hidden
States
so when outcomes influence how we think
about hidden States
this is going to be higher
and what
what does on the right
this is a triangle meaning defined as
so q s pi o
is defined as
and this looks like a Bayes theorem
situation
like kind of that chaining that Eric
just mentioned
like you have P of O condition on S and
then you have S conditioned on pi
so then those kind of like
it's like a way to get from o through S
to Pi
whereas this one on the bottom is just
like going directly about oh conditioned
on pi
which interestingly is I don't know if
this is reflected one of these or or in
some subsets of them
um one can think about that kind of
structural model like the minimum hidden
Markov model not even in its full
framing but just like what are the three
pillars of the Hidden Markov model
observations hidden States policy
yes Transitions and so on and so what is
gained by going through an intermediary
hidden state
there's going to be situations where the
observable contains a hundred percent of
the information for policy
or we can imagine situations where the
ability to choose policies
based upon s
which is where the actual pomdp is
intervening
is better
whereas in a fully observable Markov
decision process
you don't have S
you're just making decisions on o
um kind of just revisiting the point I
raised earlier about what otilda is
it seems to me that this only works
when you can when you have the
observations oh tilde
so
I I don't see how that could how it
could be anything like looking toward
the future
because if you actually want to carry
out that um
that expect that that you want to work
out what Q is
or use it you have to compute it and you
have to have the observations to compute
it and and you know the S tilde you have
to have
you know actually pipe through
and
use them so help me help me understand
if I'm wrong with that
okay here would be
um one thought the a matrix captures how
hidden States map to observations
so whether we have a really tight a
matrix or whether we have a super
dispersed a matrix
using the gaussian form for the a matrix
ensures that we can always say what the
most likely observation is
for a given hidden state
if we had a bimodal a matrix
then
there are some issues
but if we use a gaussian form
for the um like which is the laplacian
approximation
it's more tractable it's monotonic it's
more optimizable
so for a given s sequences of s
we can always derive
the expected observations
again those might have a lot of
uncertainty around them but we can
always make a sequence of O's
corresponding to any sequence of s
but this this equation makes no
expectation at all nothing says nothing
about what the form of the distribution
is that you use I mean whether it's
parametric or not parametric or whatever
it's just saying you have a distribution
Q
um
so you know then this is how we evaluate
it
yes is this true for all families of
distributions
Q
Ali what do you think about that or
anything
uh actually it's interesting that uh in
the step-by-step active inference paper
this epistemic value is defined uh
somewhat differently uh I'm not sure if
they're exactly equivalent with each
other or there's some minor uh
differences between them but uh they've
just
defined the epistemic value only in
terms of the expectation
over I mean the surprises of I mean the
difference between the qnp surprises so
we don't have
um
this kind of expression as conditioned
on the S tilde here so
yeah that's
I don't know if they're the same or not
I don't know how to copy the image into
this chat but the chat of The Gather but
or just put it put it in here put it in
the um
question
okay yeah
um well one
one thought is policy is not an
open-ended
policy in its specification is always
going to be of a finite Horizon
so if we're considering policies of
length 2.
um well so so interestingly
this is a policy that includes leading
up to the present
if this is the present
I think we had one meme that was like
what if my T minus one was was t or
something like that but
um this is a policy that right is
influencing
and this is just the variant of four
three
okay but let's just say that we're
considering policy of true future
looking length 2.
then
we're exploring different ways in which
s is going to unfold
with respect to basically B1 and B2
not using that in the superscript way to
mean like two two parallel bees but just
like there's our current there's our
estimate now
and then there's the way that that we
have you know let's just say four
affordances so there's four B ones
and then
you have now there's going to be four
options for S and then each of those
four we could apply the second
affordance again
so there's 16 policies to evaluate
each one is defined by either taking
like B1 B3 B1 B1 B4 B4
and for each of those s
in the next two time steps
we can emit
observations
Ollie
and then Rohan
sorry reminder my hand just stay away
I'm sorry
rod
my
hello yes greetings
yeah so uh going back to what the
posterior distribution is right so how
far
so is it just that isn't it just that we
assume there's a posterior distribution
of states
like an ideal posterior distribution
that we want to
that free energy that the free energy
principle moves moves the current
empirical distribution towards isn't
that I thought that's what we were going
from
the context in chapter one yes so just
just a question yeah go ahead yeah
uh yeah sorry so sorry the cohort one I
think that's what we discussed right so
it's essentially uh trying to maintain
some use races so whatever policies
uh who have performed should eventually
bring the system to that ideal
homeostatic perspective right so uh why
couldn't we just assume like a normal
distribution so even if it is fat tailed
for example if the empirical
distribution is like the key uh
distribution in this
uh formula is you know has a heavy left
tail you can essentially bring it back
towards that by essentially modifying
the policies I thought that that was the
context of this right
yes broadly you're right so when we look
at the full free energy expected free
energy formalization so here's equation
7.4 or equation 2.6 you're absolutely
right that there's a pragmatic value
that's based around reducing Divergence
between observations and preferences but
in equation the one we've been focusing
on and trying to really unpack because
again also like otilda is used in
pragmatic value
we're only talking here I mean they
would still be
yeah yeah but but that would make sense
right because uh your your conditioning
on your actions having some
uh effect on the state on your own State
and your state in the world or maybe
some state in the world so you have to
continuously monitor until it comes down
to the expected observation that's what
the generative model would spit out
right so it makes perfect sense and
it's completely coherent in that way
right
yes I
hope and slash expect and prefer that to
be true what you're describing about
like bringing the homeostatic variable
closer to preferences expectations
that is pragmatic yeah but that would
also yeah so that wouldn't it wouldn't
be surprising that hotel does that and
not be distribution as well as what I'm
saying no you wouldn't need it to be
there yeah you're right it is needed to
be there because these are surprises and
entropies and so on about observations
um and then these this part is really
digging into
um decompositions of epistemic value
so these are
there might be two policies that are
both expected to bring your temperature
down
or whatever
but they have different epistemic values
does it matter if it just brings your
temperature down well it would look the
same
um essentially it would have the same
effect so why does it matter
uh why why uh did we have to have this
kind of uh yeah so there will be
multiple policies that would bring it
down bring the temperature down if
you're if the preferences to bring the
temperature down it does not matter
which policy is chosen right so that's
essentially what I think it's being said
okay so yeah as long as you minimize the
expected here's two investment
opportunities from a hundred dollars
150 plus or minus one or 150 plus or
minus 200. which one do you want
that's not what you were discussing
um so it is because they have space is
very different no it's not the same
thing they are the payoff space expected
ambiguity in the 200 plus or minus 200
is very very different or and your
Mutual information will be very
different because the payoff space is
different exactly you are essentially
taking yeah but uh if something is going
to bring down uh temperature plus or
minus two plus or minus four I mean it's
not a huge difference as long as it
brings it down right so that that's
essentially what I'm getting at so okay
why does it matter okay so in this in
this modeling the body's expected
temperature is like the expected return
on investment
and the variance around the expected
temperature is like the variance around
the S uh Investments
and so right but they wouldn't be the
same policy is what I'm saying sorry
they won't be the same payoff space in
the second case so if something uh
generates a hundred dollars but has uh a
low probability of going bus so that
there's a high variance that's not the
same payoff as something that reduces
the same hundred dollars but is that has
a lower variance the payoff space spaces
are different and that will be captured
in that uh coolback Divergence that you
have there
that's right I would prefer the one with
the lower that's right that's right
because the payoffs yeah so uh but uh I
think the discussion was around if
multiple things lead to the same
epistemic value and they have the same
payoff why does it matter which one is
taken rate is that last piece there
might be multiple policies with the same
pragmatic value
and then then epistemic value is the
Difference Maker that favors policies
that have more clarity about observation
outcomes
right right
so pragmatic value would say would would
say that's not necessarily true right uh
that's not necessarily true let's say
that uh okay when the payoff space is
completely unknown that the steps that
you're taking uh at T equals one two
three will bring down the uh we'll we'll
have the same pragmatic value but one of
these actions will lead to some very bad
consequences that step peoples 15
because you're giving up something else
because if we're talking about
temperature we're in the space of
temperature okay so yeah
all right all right let's uh so let's
just bring it back to the finance okay
the space is dollars that's the dollar
space
uh yeah okay so we could use dollars
numeric fine so we benchmarked the
dollars how many dollars in making
profit so I have two Investments uh one
uh both of them generate a hundred
dollars but one of them requires me to
borrow a hundred dollars in order to
generate a hundred dollars the other one
will generate a hundred dollars over say
50 time steps this would be quicker
the second one where you borrow 100 so
it would be quicker because you're
borrowing a hundred dollars but there's
an interest rate that you have to uh pay
out so there's a much uh so you will
have to generate much more than a
hundred dollars in order to for this to
be viable okay because you have an
interest rate payout okay I'm gonna try
to follow up here policies are defined
in terms of sequences of affordances to
take
so the affordance here that you're
highlighting is borrowing or not
yes but there are actions that would be
like if you have a very high fever in
order to bring down that high fever
sometimes it makes sense to borrow that
hundred dollars whatever metaphorical
variation of that borrowing that you
have to bring it down to something more
manageable right
so it depends on how close you are to
some sort of threshold where it's
intolerable
uh I mean putting it in in more mundane
terms that hey I have I have a bad
toothache it doesn't make sense for me
to borrow a hundred dollars to fix my
tooth I could just brush my teeth and
hope that it goes away but I have a
knife in my back I need to get to the
hospital
it makes sense to pay a hundred dollars
because you're gonna die if you don't
look okay let me try to try to see this
is how I'm seeing that is when we're um
near homeostasis
then yeah we take actions that basically
keep us there and we try not to like add
risk to the situation whereas near the
limits of our homeostatic tolerance
we may engage in high risk behavior
because there's like already a
non-negligible like because of payoff
space is much larger yeah the payoff
space the positive payoff based on life
so when you are when you're closer to
when you're closer when you have a knife
in your back
the payoff from borrowing a hundred
dollars will save your life
but you have a toothache borrowing a
hundred dollars might cause more risk
that you go bankrupt right but you won't
you will still survive if you have the
tooth a toothache you're just short a
hundred dollars which you could have
used elsewhere
there's no way you can use that hundred
dollars if you're dead yeah so it does
it does a much higher payoff borrowing
at that point than it is with the
toothache example rates it depends on
where you take these actions I got you
I'm seeing the space
are the axes so here we have dollars and
life
and so you're saying that yeah but it is
a multi-dimensional uh this one so if
you think about it as let's say yeah so
uh let's make it more concrete right so
if you have a drone
uh and uh you have a trade-off between
battery life and staying in the air
uh and let's say one of your propellers
goes out uh you know just redistributing
power to the other mortars so that you
stay in the air even though it reduces
your uh hover time makes more sense
because you could Land versus you know
uh trying to fly around and then crash
eventually
because you've lost one motor
so but whereas let's say that uh it's so
the other option would be let's just go
faster to a certain destination
then it doesn't really make sense to do
so you're just reducing your battery
life to get to a destination faster but
uh
but if something happens on the wave
which causes you to lose your motor then
you don't have enough battery in order
to enough battery power to distribute to
the automotive so that you can hover and
come down safely
uh does it make sense
uh Eric so this
you know I wonder if we could table this
particular discussion it seems to be
going
um you know and get back to some of the
other questions in the chapter I mean if
I I actually we we had a question that
was pending from last week
that I think is kind of critical to the
understanding of the chapter and I
wonder if we could so you want to make
sure we have time for it running out of
time here yeah
um
and that's the the question about
what the relative role is of alert how
it actually operates that you learn
something that the rat learn some
information
prior to deciding which of the two
branches of the maze to take
um and the way they seem to frame the
chapter is that well they set it up so
that the rat
um has its preference
for epistemic Value because of epistemic
value of learning which of the two
branches to take
um is a is a bigger term it'll first go
to the bottom branch
and
um learn which of the two top branches
has the payoff then once that's resolved
it knows that then it go then it decides
which of the top branches to go to and
it gets its reward
so my understanding of that is that
and this is my claim in this question
is that
um the rat is
has a preference to resolve epistemic
uncertainty
regardless of whether it's useful or not
so if you added more uncertain questions
like you know um
what color is
um you know my Apple today but there's
no there's no apple to be gotten
um
it'll still want to resolve that
question and any other questions because
those are uncertainties so the epistemic
value it'll collect that epistemic value
and then finally it gets around to
collecting its reward
um that's in contrast to a model where
the purpose of resolving epistemic
uncertainty is to gain the reward which
requires look ahead so in other words
the the planner or the policy would be I
try to learn what's needed to collect
the reward I do that and that's posted
as as epistemic value with a purpose
then the the order of operation is okay
I figure out what I need to know I learn
what I need to know then I go and get
collect do the exploitation so I don't
that's what I would expect that this
kind of a framing would give us but I
don't see that that's what you're
actually giving us
all right
here here's how I see that the um
example that we would want to see
would have
a bunch of
um uncertainty resolving this one picks
a number between 1 and 10 and tells you
what it is this one's a number between
one and a million so it's an it's an
incredible information resolving button
then the question is can the relevant
sources of information be sought after
um
I think uh the examples is prepared in
several ways
for example the rat already knows the
semantics
that this is related to here
that's been just the structure of the
model
is already preparing that any any
information
any uncertainty reduction
about this like basically it's already
encoded in the model that this bottom
cue is information about this
so this
is kind of like saying
um and this relates earlier like
not only are the those those like
implicit structurally encoded
aspects of knowledge
but also there's parameterization
questions like we discussed
if it really pers if it has a dire
urgency
for food
to um the earlier questions about like
the urgency of the imperative it may
just go for it
and say I'd rather have a 50 50 shot now
than a 98 in two time steps
so it depends on how it's parameterized
but even more deeply it depends on the
construction of the model
what kinds of relationships are
implicitly and explicitly being linked
and like that's a a it's like a deep
level of
modeling
to understand what would be like a more
neutral way
to frame
this question and it's like well how
many layers back do you want to pull
like you could have a pre-play
where a rat has um an association Matrix
there's three information sources
and it's allowed to freely explore
without any shock or food and determine
which one of these information sources
has like a causal relationship to these
edges and then there's a learned cue
that now we're in game time
and now it's going to rely on its past
learning about which information
resource is relevant for the pragmatic
value
and then it's I mean there's just how
many layers back does one need to pull
before the rabbit is not in the Hat
I think is going to be a serious
question
because even toy demonstrations have
been seen as slam dunk
and
um they're not
well instead of bringing up Palm DPS
here Palm DPS are really good for
planting but they don't have this rat do
any planning it seems like they're
really not
aspiring very strongly to build a smart
rat here and they're not achieving it
either
yeah it's um true because
uh
here
the first movement again
presuming that the parameterization is
such that epistemic value is salient
the first move is dominated by epistemic
value and they say well now that that
value has been tapped now it can step
into pursuing pragmatic value with even
increased confidence
um
but it's not considering
this the set of time Horizon 2 policies
that is not being explicitly encoded
or
that means that even implicit yeah these
are these are transition matrices
these are just the four options this is
this is depending on where you are
you can if you're you know you can stay
you can go down
yeah does section seven three address
planning
and if it doesn't why do we need G
why can't we just use a one-step
variational free energy approximation
what's it's it's saying what's the most
likely thing for me for me to do right
now
is a question about now in the past
well I think the answer to the question
is exactly as you said it before which
is they baked in this particular
hardwired rat for which in this case it
it the best thing to do is to First
explore learn and then exploit so they
designed it to do only this very by
wrote to do the right thing as opposed
to the rat actually
use it doing any look ahead or any
intelligence to do the right thing yeah
it's structurally implicitly hardwired
and then it's fine-tuned
because again there's structures where
it wouldn't do this and there's tunings
where it wouldn't do this
but there's there's um
it's cut kind of in in the tens place
and in the decimal point
this example exists in a very limited
manifold
of models and parameterizations where
one step optimal policies emulate
two-step planning
like I just happened to love sacrificing
pawns and taking castles so I'm willing
to sacrifice upon so that later I can do
a castle but of course you can't walk
around with the belief that you love
sacrificing Pawns
yeah
I actually wondered why there was an
enumeration of policies in the planning
section
um
okay
learning hyper priors
hidden States on hidden States
seeing hidden States as outcomes
of other
hidden States
so that they can be learned or fixed
a little bit of technical details on
um on a multi-parameter minimization
Theta being just a vector of parameters
for the generative model
and dear Schley distributions which I
think
could be gotten into but that's kind of
distribution specific
creatures select the most appropriate
data to improve their generative models
I think there's more that we can dig
into and explore on similar wavelengths
like
risk plus ambiguity but then now there's
an Information Gain
I thought we just had risk plus
ambiguity
then we didn't really
yeah people point to structure learning
but don't they always
as a way to get around these questions
but then it's the structure of the
structure learner
and then people end up with these Turing
machines
that don't plan
people hope that Bayesian model
reduction
will be attractable and provide
heuristics for structure learning
but I haven't seen any empirical
examples that come to mind
where Beijing model reduction was used
to identify actionable
lower dimensional
useful models
but we know that structure learning on
the state space of hierarchical models
is going to be essential active
inference or Beyond because
people thought that the explosions the
the computational complexity class of
just branching time active inference or
anything within a model
this is going to be like exploding upon
that by several exponents
and we have these fundamental questions
about the continuous time interpolations
why are there continuous interpolations
in chapter seven
but it's the discrete Time chapter
okay
next time we come to chapter eight I
think this will be quite interesting
we're going to talk about dynamical
systems motor control
um lockabletera we'll have some
Justified continuous lines
um LaPlace assumption Lorenz live stream
number 32 stochastic chaos and Markov
blankets
Hybrid models with discrete continuous
Fusion
and
some advances in continuous time
modeling
thanks everybody
see you soon
thanks everyone